you may now kiss the bride okay one of
those hi I'm Zack and I'm single as [ __ ]
that don't fall in love with me
hi I'm Ashley I'm gonna marry Zack for a
week probably a huge mistake it's gonna
be great thank you you're welcome
honestly well the time I love being
single
I really do I do whatever I want
whenever I want I'm an independent woman
I've never had to plan my life around
another person I'm not good at letting
people into my life
committing to another person for the
rest of your life
it's a crazy justify party to run up I
want to be in relationships I do at some
point I want to share my life with
someone and the logistics of that seem a
little frightening
this is like immersion therapy I'm gonna
carry me over the threshold how will you
carry me why are you so much [ __ ]
because we're gonna be together for a
week vortex a day five meals over the
course of a week two nice things that
are completely unplanned each let's just
do one where do I put my stuff oh my god
I didn't think about this I guess I'll
have to move my kimono so I think at
some point I'm just gonna want him to
shut up
we're really I'm making your bed it's
our bed and I know he is definitely
gonna want me to shut up the only CD
that I have in my cards Taylor slicker
than I just like almost a year old now
it's but it doesn't matter it's the
biggest CD like most married couples is
gonna be completely sexless did you say
that's accurate no how do you sleep at
sleep a fetal position like a little
baby you have to be comfortable around
the other person brought me makes you
fart
I assume it's gonna teach me a lot about
myself best part about being married so
far Ashley has John citrus mimosa
shampoo I smell like a damn tree
definitely gonna teach me a lot about
Ashley the Wonder Woman pajamas if I'll
get some alcohol maybe we'll want
popsicles cool
Thank You Ashley eye on the prize it's
been similar so far to Friendship but
it's just longer yeah this is a long one
friendship and with retainer don't fall
in love with me I'm saying that that's a
little you know very cheap that's it for
me the hardest thing to conceptualize is
like your freedom is just gone actually
told me if she wants a divorce I do that
was stressing me out so much we need to
talk this out even in the second day of
marriage we started resenting how much
time we were spending together and
that's not good
you know Adam asked me to get dinner and
I said no I'm gonna order dinner for my
wife I thought there have got to be
moments where you have panic about like
oh my god I just signed up for the rest
of my life having made up from our fight
yeah yeah
because I got funny snapchat of you my
hair looks stupid okay facili
you definitely need a time where you're
just not even engaging with other person
and it's not rude I hate planning dates
oh it's such a nightmare it just
stresses me out it pumpkin we're gonna
be late for a double dinner with date
with the pho Merce another thing is
hanging out with your couples friends so
you're gonna go on a date night you're
gonna double date with me and Ariel it's
great we brought wine white wine we're
late but Zack found a great partner yeah
we don't have any pictures of us making
out in our homes we don't have any
pictures of us in general this so adults
date night with the farmers made me
realize why people get married what's
your trick when you're out of play for
our wives having for our wives
incuse act for lime date night with her
faux MERS was the [ __ ] they made a
really delicious dinner which I'm not
accustomed to anyone cooking for me I
could have - like a friend cooked for me
how delightful is that there really is a
moment in every adults life where you're
like just tired of being single
would you get bored though of this if
this is your whole life I don't know I
don't think so
that was wonderful shall we go home now
tomorrow absolute price tomorrow has
some surprises in store if you actually
are you drunk drunken love drunk on
marriage I realized I've never planned a
romantic day for anyone
I hate planning dates today is like a
day of niceties and surprises Zak had so
many surprises for me it was [ __ ]
crazy having a special day that's like
this is our date night it encourages you
to think outside the box
because it's like not my birthday or
anything it's just my marriage Ashley
loves theme parks and it's been hot as
balls out so later today we'll go into a
water park I got one more thing before
the water park now we're a family
married couples probably no go to water
parks unless they have kids but like
that's kind of married couple to the
test of like can Ashley a night to spend
a ton of time together and not like feel
radon they're gonna kill each other and
when we see it
we both said as soon as we got home like
I had a fun day I don't want to be with
you anymore
so we're just gonna sit next to each
other and try and be alone in the same
room final marriage marriage we're going
to my favorite place Oh
Monday was our final day it was kind of
bittersweet and the weird thing was last
night it felt so normal I forgot for a
second that this I wasn't like actually
married I got mostly cruised so is
healthy it's nice to have someone who's
always on your team and marriage really
is teamwork I think this is all married
people do she's watchful eyes to get
better choice now that it's over I'm
like kind of sad I don't promise that
ready divorce on three one two three
divorce
oh no marriage is [ __ ] hard y'all you
really can't put yourself first
and that is like what it's scary to open
yourself to another human being but it
can also be really rewarding and I see
that now
I want to get married soon thank you
yeah totally but not to each other maybe
a little but not not really don't fall
in love Ashley that's my line we called
each other pumpkin throughout the week I
heard someone else call Ashley pumpkin
and I got furious I was like back the
[ __ ] off that's my pumpkin
sexual intimacy is a big part of any
relationship different video okay